una postal navideña en forma de 140
centímetros de nieve en Búfalo este
miércoles la segunda ciudad más grande
del estado de Nueva York despertó bañada
por el blanco tras una tormenta que dejó
decenas de Muertos durante el fin de
semana Y puso los termómetros con grados
a bajo cero
durante la tormenta fue bastante
horrible el viento aullaba y la nieve
iba a la deriva
Hay algún supermercado abierto pero
están teniendo dificultades para
abastecerse hay algo de pan pero se han
quedado sin leche y sin huevos
[Música]
Y es que esta es la mayor tormenta que
ha registrado Estados Unidos en los
últimos 50 años ante su ferocidad muchos
intentaron huir quedaron atrapados en
sus autos y murieron congelados sin
posibilidad de acceso para los equipos
de rescate razón a por la que el
gobierno local ha prohibido conducir y
está intentando restablecer el
suministro eléctrico y despejar las
carreteras
habíamos limpiado alrededor del 70% de
las calles de la ciudad de Buffalo
después de esta tormenta histórica
nuestra flota de nieve junto a otros
equipos continúan su trabajo de despejar
la ciudad
lejos de un cuento de Navidad este
fenómeno extremo ha hecho de estas en
las peores navidades para muchas
familias en el país con al menos uno
coma siete millones de personas
afectadas por los cortes de Electricidad
y cientos de carreteras bloqueadas y
vuelos a cancelados